ja sage und schreibe mittlerweile sechs
monate krieg in der ukraine und wir
wollen uns auch heute in die
militärische lage im land ansehen und
wir wollen uns den osten ansehen das
erste video was wir haben ist aus der
region donetsk im osten des landes dort
versucht die russische armee weiter
vorzudringen denn hierbei der stadtbach
mut das ist eine der der strategisch
wichtigen orte wo russland versucht
weiter vorzudringen allerdings ist auch
kaum schafft und wir haben neue
aufnahmen aus bach mut also genau aus
dieser region und wir sehen hier immer
mehr bilder die uns erinnern ja an das
was wir schon seit 2014 in der ukraine
gesehen haben nämlich nicht mehr ein
großes hin und her mit waffen mit
panzern usw mit luftwaffe sondern dieser
grabenkrieg wir sehen dass hier
ausgehobene tiefe gräben mit 123 45
sandsäcken übereinander wo sich eben
diese soldaten gegenüberstehen von
beiden seiten ähnliches videos gibt es
auch von russischer seite und quasi in
ihren gräbern einige hundert meter
voneinander entfernt aufeinander
schießen diese situation hatten wir
schon nach den ersten feindseligkeiten
2014 und zwischen 2015 und 2022 sind
monatlich immer noch so zwischen
20 und bis zu 100 soldaten gestorben bei
dieser art von kämpfen in den gräben und
es sieht immer mehr danach aus als
würden diese grabenkämpfe zurückkommen
weil keine seite weder die russen in
ihre offensive noch die ukraine ihnen
ihr gegenoffensive es schaffen den
gegner hier zu verdrängen wir schauen
uns allerdings auch weitere bilder an
und zwar hier ein ja auch ein seltenes
exemplar wenn man so will war zu sehen
ist hier in einem wald versteckt eine
sogenannte csu 23.4 das ist ein vier
links geschützt ein vier
jahre geschützt der flugabwehr wir sehen
uns jetzt einmal hier im foto von 1965
der sowjetischen armee das hat sich hier
versteckt auf russischer seite und die
ukraine machen das was sie am besten
können sie gehen da wahrscheinlich auch
mit alternativen wir sehen nämlich die
einschläge kommen immer näher an dieses
csu 23.4 die da versteckt es an dieses
flugabwehr gerät und irgendwann treffen
sie dann wir sehen hier diesen weißen
lkw auf der einen seite der scc unten zu
sehen und da sehen wir die überreste von
diesem alten geschützt das heißt das
gibt es auch weiter in dieser artillerie
kämpfe also wir haben zwar die neue
drohen aufnahme darauf aber ansonsten
haben wir tatsächlich
sowjetische artillerie gegen sowjetische
flugabwehr der russin die sich hier
bekämpfen zuallerletzt wollen wir uns
ansehen
dieses exemplar das foto wurde gestern
vom litauischen
verteidigungsminister veröffentlicht und
es handelt sich hier um die türkische
bayraktar tb2 drohne die von litauen in
einer crowdfunding aktion zusammen
finanziert wurde am ende hat der
türkische hersteller dass das ding dann
verschenkt aber das ist ganz wichtig die
rosa mehrmals behauptet dass diese
drohne abgeschossen wurde die litauer
wollen wir zeigen dass das nicht der
fall ist und wir sehen einmal hier nach
oben in die ecke hier haben wir also
russische artillerie die sich auf den
angriff vorbereitet hier der lkw der
zieht da die artillerie und hier die
munition und diese drohne wir sehen es
schon an diesem ziel zielfernrohr
zählt hier auf die munition und wir
sehen dass gleich auch gleich wie der
treffer erfolgt auf der munition das
spricht also zum einen dafür wie
zielgenau jetzt sehen wir es wie
zielgenau diese drohne hier schießt und
zum anderen eben dafür dass die litauer
ganz klar machen wollen und auch die
ukraine klar machen wollen anders als
die russische armee behauptet wurde
diese drohne bislang nicht abgeschlossen
sondern ist weiter im einsatz nachdem
crowdfunding das litauische bürger
bekämpft sie also rosig der artillerie
stellungen in der ukraine
[Musik]